okay welcome to our basically weekly
meeting on incremental language
development we will be hitting 500 hours
of live-streaming a few minutes into
this so thanks to everybody who's
watched these and for lots of terrific
comments suggestions things that have
improved our products and added
interesting ideas actually were going to
start from one that comes from someone
who's watched these live streams Pete
more costs who we've been talking about
this function that we've been calling
spliced for about two years now and
we've never liked the name and Pete has
said your name is terrible and he's got
some better suggestions and this is kind
of our 11th hour moment to change the
name for 12.1 and I want to start off by
talking about that okay so the main the
okay people on the live stream are
talking about what am I going to talk
about the physics project very very soon
I just came from a meeting working on
some of the launch plans for that I am
working actually harder than I have
worked I work very hard as some of you
may know but I'd been working more
intensely than I can remember having
done in decades on this project to try
and get it ready so that I can present
it to people we've got I kind of got
what is now about a 300 page document
that is sort of the the basic story of
what's going on we've actually been
recording all of the working sessions
that have led to all of this it's about
300 hours of recordings now they
wouldn't make a lot of sense without the
context so there's not much point in
putting them out there yet
but I am hoping we are within a month of
being able to to present all the stuff
it's gone
really great it's really really
wonderful fascinating deeply abstract
quite a tower of different kinds of
abstractions which is why you know the
pieces won't make won't make sense
without without being able to show more
of the context but I'm I'm I'm super
looking forward to being able to share
that with people and it's coming very
soon I'm working hard on it um all right
I'm back back - yeah I I you know to be
clear the reason I've been doing less
live-streaming well part of the reason
is because of the 12.1 release and we're
in kind of bug fixing and finishing mode
and part of it is because I've been
spending all my time working on the
physics project alright refocus um we're
talking about some things that splice
into lists okay and of which nothing was
our original kind of model and I think
the point that Peters been making which
he is not wrong about is we are trying
to describe where the word spliced we're
trying to describe what happens rather
than what the thing is and since the
thing that sits there it's a what it is
is more important so let's sum yeah so
this type of thing sequence replace well
it's not quite the story is it because
sequence replace would not insert would
insert that as a list right it wouldn't
insert it as a sequence right the point
there is that he suggested to do it
directly in replace I think that may be
quite wrong to have to implement right
that's a different issue I mean that
will be put in making sequence replace
able to be called directly from replaced
which i think is interesting but I think
that's a that's a future enhancement I
think the main issue here is I mean that
there's a problem in having anything
here because replaces such a structural
operation as soon
we have anything here if you want to do
matter programming and replace that
thing without replacing it as a you get
what I'm saying it's going to get very
complicated I'm I'm I'm a little bit
concerned about that but um so this is a
no op right here I mean the the spliced
on the left-hand side of this is a no op
isn't it well it works as as as given in
the next one so what I was thinking is
perhaps you can generalize the previous
one so it's more symmetric if you're
working with spliced objects oh yeah
yeah you should absolutely allow that
about that first thing I completely
agree okay yes and and because we don't
have a pattern sequence doesn't allow
doing similar things you have to
construct the full object preparing
patterns for for the left and right
sides
I was wondering with their pattern
sequencer now something like that I
don't think it does by itself right so
let's see pattern sequence what is the
relationship now I'm confused about an
additional point the relationship a
pattern sequenced to the future of
spliced but the sequence is something
that is understood by replace and
replace home and can take a pattern but
sorry sorry
what does pattern sequence do well it
accepts more general things like that so
this is a trivial case but it to
complete general patterns inside
right right so it is it is something
very much like I mean this this idea of
a list fragment or something would work
the same way as this if I'm not mistaken
similarly and in fact sequence replace
uses internally pattern sequence River
I'm still missing the point of what this
actually does um so to me this is the
left hand side version of things while
splice is the right hand side version of
things yes although this is more general
and this works in any function not just
list right yes and this you know this
has doesn't have the explode on contact
version because you know issue because
it is um yeah right okay um we reached
our 500 hours yeehaw okay um I don't
know what 500 hours there must be these
principles about after you've been doing
something for some amount of time I
think it's I think it's like 10,000
hours just supposed to be an expert um
and but um I think altogether we've been
doing these design reviews for a lot
more than 500 hours but at least we've
been able to share 500 hours of them um
okay let's come back to this um the
so coming back here okay so the thing
we're mostly talking about here is
basically naming yeah I mean the first
point is something see um say I'm trying
to confused by this thing so Pete Mikasa
was the person who kindly sent in a
bunch of detailed suggestions just sent
something to the live stream but I am
trying to understand what is that was
sent and I'm not completely getting it
so somebody can resend that to me in a
form that's easier for me to digest that
would be good okay um first other
questions on our live stream here Carl
is asking about and you're on that's
live stream yeah we could do that
actually um we're certainly gonna be
talking about the Gans stuff that's
coming I don't know whether people other
than me will probably talk about that in
more detail I will certainly be doing a
12.1 live stream once twelve point one
is ready to roll which should be in a
small number of weeks question is are
that all the redmine open issue is going
to be resolved for twelve one the I
don't know the answer to that I doubt
that they'll all be resolved but um I
think um I think it we should be doing
another another iteration of commenting
on those issues and suggestions and I
don't know why there hasn't been
scheduled um let's see
you
okay uh all right so Peters sending
through some sample English sentences
which is a useful thing to do um okay
I'm not sold on a multiple items thing I
like the word multiple I don't like the
word items
um I mean listing in the name may be
useful to denote the fact that these
aren't response in lists yes I don't
even understand this one here because
this is this is using it more like
sequence I mean that's a this whole
issue I mean this will certainly this
will search should certainly work right
and that works with spliced yes right
yes um what is this one here yeah the
next case
if we tried to use that with sequence
sequence with supplies inside if too
ugly and so that's that's useful too oh
I see what this is doing I get it I get
it I gotta go that's nice actually
that's actually very nice use case yeah
I know
horrifying yeah um well I do like the
multiple being you know cuz it is what
it's doing it's representing multiple
items I don't disagree the problem is
the word item has a bit of a troubled
history um alright let's look at some of
our other things I think we're thinking
about these I was considering subtlest
given that it's what we use in the
sequence xxx functionality and will soon
have subset which feel so close but
doesn't suggest that it's an active
thing I mean subset is what a subset do
now we have created the subset function
subsequent subset positions similar to
sequence to see yes I understand
subset position and so on but but I
don't but they they have a very
different set up than this thing okay so
let's write down the suggestions that we
have on the table I think there were a
couple that I made in did you capture
the ones that I made in the email that I
sent um we have is a correspondence in
class one this in the next section okay
at the end I think the last subsections
yeah and in the very first section I
tried to give the full list of names
that were suggested what was the one
that I suggested can you pin the first
subsection of the first section of the
material yes okay right so I do think we
should consider the non list case I I do
think that's interesting as a thing to
as an inserter to go into other things
for example um
you know the issue is when does it
unpack um we had considered that
situation and our main worry is that
because this works currently as an a
value it wasn't necessarily work in some
cases like holding objects sorry which
I'm sorry what are you saying that that
I mean the case that I'm thinking about
is there are functions that just happen
to take various things and you want this
to be I don't know it's like some of the
more mathematical functions that happen
to where you want to package it you
don't want to have to say what's a good
example yeah okay yeah outer F and then
then you want to say something like
argument sequence blah blah blah but now
we're that's a list and we're the only
you know currently you would do sequence
at at which is really horrifying and the
idea would be the question is when does
this explode on contact so to speak and
you know one way to do that would be to
have some kind of tagging that says this
happens and outer only another
possibility would be to have some kind
of Bank of things in which it can happen
more like list of all for example I mean
what this is is unpack a ball in the
same kind of way that listing list is
unpack a ball
um right so I mean this is the analog so
we could imagine so let's let's explore
this possibility we could imagine a
class of functions that are not uh this
is the opposite of list of all lists of
all just means this this is you ingest
this into the very innards of the
function itself right rather than you've
got a list here and instead of instead
of listing the function over it you are
inserting that as a ver args thing too
I'm saying
that's too technical and horrifying for
that but I I mean ok we're so it isn't
really Vera it's really what what does
it say what does it want to say it wants
to say this is an attribute of a
function that would mean this is a
function in which this packaging will
unpack right without you telling it to
do so and their functions were it
wouldn't happen
like for instance I mean okay what will
be the cart what be the category of
functions in which that'll it might be
some arguments of those functions this
unpacking would happen am I making sense
yes it's a bit in the same way that
sequence always compacts and we have the
a cubed sequence hold do you want the
opposite it never unpacks but you want
to force it that's correct that's
correct
right there's a class of functions in
which it unpacks I mean I think that
list of all you know now 30 something
years old has been a very successful
attribute in most of the time does what
people expect it has some issues but
most of the time it does what people
expect um
you
okay let's understand this notion of
generalization about police because I
haven't really understood this me
neither I think this is really our
values and Pete Markos was suggesting
this example of Paris next which I think
we can do with some values become
someone's our values because they become
active when inside a specific head I see
I see I see I mean the issue without
values which it was one of those things
where you know 33 years ago when I
originally invented up values the idea
that they would only go up one level was
a let's put this into begin with and see
if we ever need to go further and in the
third of a century we haven't needed to
go further but it surprised me that we
haven't needed to go further I mean
occasionally we do and there are some
interaction between up values and sub
values that don't work very well I'm
making sense I mean like like for
example a typical case where we have we
run into trouble is f of G of X of H of
X where we want to hang something on
somehow on the G of X
right and we can't do that right now
right although there's nothing on the
concept about values that would prevent
that just doesn't happen to work um I
think it's a matter of implementation
and combinatorics the more levels it has
to explore this lower it could be sure
but I mean I don't think we've looked at
this in years how to think about this I
think it could be looked at again and
particularly as we work on you know the
compiler meets the evaluator that might
be a possibility but okay let's so let's
not worry about that for right now okay
let's go back here to where do we have
the list of names okay um we just
suggesting worst list signals all right
so let's take a look again
you
see I worry that people will read
multiple items in the wrong way as more
like multiply
you
and I just said we have item used in so
many places in relation to typesetting
yeah I agree I'm just right random words
here for a second
this isn't right these aren't right one
thing that I found surprisingly
successful which I was a name I was
worried about was any true and all true
and that family I was worried about
those but they've actually worked out
well as far as I'm concerned um I mean
the trouble is we would really love to
have this not sound technical because it
isn't a technical concept really um okay
Peters commenting about this active
Values thing that suggests the pattern
of nothing has placed expense to other
things that need to make local
structural modifications and so can't be
done as a single replacement i suture
saying that the container in which they
live
um the um is being a
by whatever is happening with them I
agree um yes I had thought about
multiple elements um gosh how do we make
this yeah I mean I thought about I was
thinking about things like several items
but that's not very good several oh dear
everybody
this is this is one of these you know
sometimes with this naming thing you
nail it in no time at all I remember one
of our all-time worst naming Horrors was
manipulate which in the end I think we
got a good name for but boy did that
take a lot of time and did it go through
so many to word you know dynamic
interaction something or other things
okay so what we're looking for is
something that represents this idea of
multiple um and unfortunately multiple
on its own see this is where this is
such a a it's a funny thing how language
you know the concepts that we have sort
of developed okay now I'm going
philosophical here sort of the concepts
we've developed as a as a civilization
both mold well it's just it's very
awkward that there are just certain
words and they have yeah anyway um it's
a pity we can't just go back and
redesign the whole of the way that we
communicate I mean we're trying to do
our little part of that um
all right let's see trying to think
about
see unfortunately things like the the
many
collection and so on and so on and so on
they all have the sense of
really what this is is we're treating
this thing
this is a packaged version of multiple
items
well the fact that it could have only
one is would that be a problem for
multiple latest works a lot understand
point I was looking at all the names we
have a small T inside you know and none
of them is a multipolar so multi
something's
let's look at list fragment for a minute
it's a pity
c'mere verb
you
you
all right we'll look at list elements
let's look back here
you
let's look at our examples where do we
have
you
what on earth with verse so that that's
an observation from peat necrosis 1 the
fact that it will be good if spliced
spliced inside itself and it already
does he was a hissed Indies when there
was an internal list and it was a bark
object but I think it's an interesting
point that it now that's it that much
because we have the internal list
oh you mean splice splices itself yeah
yeah right right because because it has
because spliced is not very odd but has
a list splice can splice things into
itself let's take this example if this
said
the unfortunate list elements again has
yeah call was pointing out list element
sounds like a diem
well so Peters pointing out that you
know how you say these things which I
agree with is you know replace the X
with fill in what you'd say I mean which
you might have said is replace the X
with the sequence blah blah blah except
that we have a technical meaning for
that
so perhaps lists sequence it's not that
because it's a particular case of
sequence for lists well I know it's why
I suggested it um is it confusing with
respect to other uses of sequence I mean
it would allow us to go for argument
sequence for the other thing which I
think is quite nice yes I wonder whether
people was expected to be barak like
sequences yeah okay well let's let's
discuss replace X with look replace X
with the spliced is pretty horrible
you'd end up saying with a spliced
object yes
I mean we had discussed before some of
these in line words but I think they're
the wrong metaphor
you
boy it's so frustrating when it's hard
to figure stuff out um all right come on
other people here speak up other people
are here I know
is Danny here suggest something crazy
I'm gonna pick on somebody if nobody
like Nick for example suggests something
crazy yeah I was trying to think of
something related to bundled or packaged
mm-hmm parceled a completely different
metaphor than we've ever had before
yeah it's trained it'd take a different
way to approach no I agree I agree I
mean I think a one word version of
something that is a packaged up
collection of elements stuffed it's
maybe a little elements yeah elements is
too generic stuff just too like a bear
yeah and we have like the the internal
stuff bags sort of notion but it's a
little different what is something like
the parcel what is something that is a
package that is packaged up a parcel a
package a a thing that has a container
you know what I'm saying
but isn't this the opposite analogy we
want because we want something that will
it's like it doesn't have a cover around
it and it will splice Amanat peeled we
had the peeled idea but but that was a
but that again is like spliced I mean
peeled is like spliced the idea is no no
that the idea here is to represent that
this is a package which will be unpacked
so to speak bundle I think that's used
for too many other things yeah
Paquette is also used for other things
yeah
I mean I think these things that say you
know like rapper we've we've often used
the term rapper for other things I think
we're gonna wind up using rapper to mean
something that stays there what we need
here is a is a form of packaging which
expects to be unpacked this is a thing
where you're going to you know this will
automatically unpack which is why we
ended up with spliced because we're
concentrating all those Matic on packing
but this is now the idea that this is a
thing that is uh I mean by the way just
to give people another sense of naming I
mean Association was another thing was a
pretty hard one name um which is again
been a good name um it's a little
abstract but it um you know if this
construct is widely used which I think
it will be people you know it it has
allowed a little amount of abstraction
because people will learn what it means
so as it connotes the right thing um
yeah I sad or suggesting things like
chunk and lump um the problem of the
container is you expect it to stay what
we need is a we already say element
sequence way too long way too abstract
in my view say
mint okay so one that I think is
interesting here but as is some as one
from Ethan our livestream sequence
graphed which suggests the word graphed
but I think it's too weird sir no good
um I was going to say that I'm looking
at ceilings of sequence in this chain
it's not gonna work I don't think chain
is gonna work but I think that the yeah
peter is remarking that he thinks should
be a plural word and I am I think it'd
be much nicer if it didn't have to be a
plural word because that would save the
confusion of a single element there and
[Music]
although I mean it does have the
advantage okay a plural word has the
advantage of knowing you are potentially
putting multiple things gosh there are
so many of these words that mean you
know what you need is this thing what is
a metaphor for this where where the
thing is automatically opened out and oh
boy there's got to be something in the
world where you expect to put it in and
it immediately sort of kind of like okay
in a text editor
you obviously are something good in the
word sequence is that it is a similar
but it represents a collection so there
must be other words like that
um let's see what about insertion
something around that no it's hopeless
it's unreadable X is an insertion
you
you
you
yeah some suggestions on livestream
are interesting like envelope but it
isn't the right thing because that is
the thing itself it is not what we the
whole point is we want to focus on
what's inside not the wrapper itself
you
in fusion interesting suggestion but
technical sounding better than graft
what does it what is the word when you
know when you want something to
I mean I don't like the the you know
concept of you know the skin graft type
graft thing but when you want something
when you are putting something into
something and you want it to just sort
of melt into the thing that it was put
into
what are some metaphors around that idea
dissolving yeah but but I hardly think
we're going to a dissolution seems like
it's a dissolved also it's not great
right I mean but we want the concept of
it is the thing it is not the act of
dissolving it is the thing that will be
dissolved into that will be dissolved
into the solvent yes
you
notion have carried to make any sense
carried what does that mean you got a
bunch of suggestions on a live stream
about things like melt and so on but I
think again that is not what we're you
know actually Pete's really good point
which I thank him for is name the thing
not the action that's gonna happen to it
in other words we got a name the thing
you are putting in there
not um
not either its container or you know
what you're naming is the thing that's
going in there um
and salute is way way too weird and
doesn't get the sequencing part of it I
mean what were once is what is it what
is a metaphor in um I mean splice comes
from things like you know movie editing
and so on or you know traditional film
you know old-fashioned film editing
where you literally you know you splice
something into the what are some other
words that are what's another example of
way you put something into something
like a text editor for example you
insert a piece of text and it you know
it once you've inserted it you wouldn't
know the difference so to speak it's
just become one with the rest of the
text
um guess there's like entwined or
braided no but you see those you're not
naming the right thing they're not
naming the thing itself mmm but you got
a name is the thing itself the whole
point with a graft which is interesting
but I think unusable is it is you know
there is both the action of doing the
graft but there is the graft itself
which is the thing that you know you
know I'm saying yeah the thing that goes
in there the implants itself they see
that that's a oops it's a bit too weird
sounding but it's an interesting concept
I didn't misspell it did I know it's
implant its I am yeah
the fact that I'm even asking that
question is a very bad sign um
intertwine
strand yeah the problem with strand is
that it's it's a what is the thing come
on some other metaphors beyond splicing
at the films and some texture
thinking like in in woodworking if you
insert a good point to another piece in
your in laying it is an in lie a bit of
a weird metaphor yeah
little reminds me of inset yeah I mean
an example of a weird metaphor that we
were very concerned about was the so
leap metaphor but I think that one has
worked mm-hmm I like that one how
obscure is the word in lay need reminds
me merely of overlay which we already
have what does it mean it sounds like a
typesetting thing but it does mean
roughly the right thing i I'm not
pushing it that hard I don't think it
quite works but maybe something I mean
these are different directions than
we've gone in before I mean that one to
me that's okay keep thinking of
metaphors in the world for things like
this an inlay in a piece of wood
something which once inserted be nice to
get the sequence aspect of it in there
as well though um
I think it's too weird and it's too
weird for you know non-native English
speakers and things like that with an
inlay it's just a weird word
Dallas Hills probably going in the wrong
direction to a dovetail you know I think
it's very amusing at least if we needed
to ionize it it would be funny yeah um
yeah I I agree with the comments on the
live stream that in layers is nice but
not it's a bit too metaphorical visual
um alright we're gonna get there guys
we're gonna get there
Oh patch patches interesting patches an
interesting word unfortunately people
yeah it's too much it sounds too much
like fixing a bug but it is again an
interesting word another thing that that
is a a patch I mean okay the problem
with patch is you don't expect it to
disappear right the whole point of some
of these other ones is like a graft for
example you expect it to disappear once
it's once it's been inserted yeah an
embed is we've kind of used embed for
other things and I think it will be hard
to understand that embed is a noun is
being used as a noun um it's whimsical
but
spackle is something that what heard of
it it it's the like if you have a hole
in your drywall the material uses called
spackle it basically fills in the void
and disappears I have never heard that
word in my life how is it spelled that's
a bad sign you I think you are lost but
its BAC K le okay well that's but again
again we don't want this - it is not a
piece of grout so to speak it is not a
pure filler it is something that is has
real content but it is being inserted
its absorbed by the parent material your
call is counting that things like thread
are very knitting related um okay okay
guys come on we're getting there here
very frustrating process but but I like
I mean and I really would love to have a
one word thing if we can do it but then
okay so let's let's look at the ones
that are still alive here list sequin
the sort of still alive I wish it wasn't
so long and I wish it didn't have the
confusion of the virág thing my
favorites are this sequence and sublist
list could be generalized to sub
expression for the inner concept my
preference is sub list what is Stan sub
list x goes to the sub list ABC well
it's a list because it will be insert
that ended on the list um well it's
definitely it's been a okay so let's
let's look at that one but don't you say
a list of sub lists ABCD etc in other
words sub list doesn't sub list suggests
that it is still a thing absorbed can
you open the page of sequence position
just in fact I didn't know then on live
stream is saying that Lisp used the term
splices for this um coalescence yeah I
mean we're trying to name we're looking
for an out here okay which page which
should I look for secrets position
[Music]
okay so your so the current suggestion
here
yeah but remember sorry I'm people who
are commenting on languages using things
like splice I don't know what other
people have done for this but I think
they are not trying to name the symbolic
object that does this they are trying to
name the operation of doing it which is
different the whole point is that what
we're doing here we've had you know the
operation of doing this like flatten for
millions of years um well at least 33
years um
you
um so so okay let's let's review
let's look at Pete's helpful suggestions
for sentences here okay okay so let's
take this one as an example so we'd say
okay in a big list zero goes to the sub
but that's not bad
goes to the sub list
yeah
let's try this one
insert well that's not bad
in certain ABC the sub list as a sub
list they see that the problem is as a
sub list doesn't really work because
when we we say sub list to mean that
list is still there it depends how we
write it we could say sub list of ABC
like we do with sequence that we we name
the objects the whole thing all right
what do you thing with sequence what and
I'm thinking about how to document it
how to write it in there in the
reference page
yes represents a woman let's see what
you did for spliced so far yeah I mean
look we managed to wordsmith it headless
headless would have been a good name for
sequence actually headless would have
been a really good name for sequence
wish she had a time machine to go back
and do that that would have been a good
name because it would have suggested
that it's something weird we should
remember that that's a that's a what I'm
saying cuz that's effectively what what
sequence is is a headless object that's
a really interesting idea for that hmm
good idea I mean that that's in the you
know that's in the sort of Department of
nothing's
that's interesting I mean if we ever if
we ever needed to tweak how sequence
works
headless would be an interesting
direction can we can we make sure we
make we note that down for sure yes yeah
make note um okay the documentation the
sequences says sequences automatically
spliced in oh my gosh um he's saying
just go back to this place this this
business with naming is one of the most
painful it's so painful because because
sometimes you get it in 15 seconds and
sometimes it takes years the absolutely
worst case in my life is naming the
science of exploring the computational
universe I have tried so many names for
that without coming up with anything I
really like I hit my most recent one was
um because I have reasons to want to
name it again and I you know it's kind
of cyber zoology or something but that's
completely the wrong that has completely
the wrong connotations um although I was
feeling that that was what I was doing
recently exploring a bunch of different
weird rules and what they do but anyway
that that's been my all-time worst
naming experience because every every
possible word for that from all the
classical kinds of languages has been
taken a zillion times for a zillion
different things
yeah when placed inside a list
represents multiple top-level elements
right what about headless list no
because it's not it's not the right
thing cuz that would be very odd among
other things I think that's very weird
headless headless list suggested
something you shouldn't look headless
suggests it's something it's a little
bit funky to do right it's something a
little weird which is what I think
should be thought about sort of with
sequence the thing that some okay we're
getting suggestions for the science um
okay we have two senses of list here the
fact that it contains a list and the
fact that is it splices into a list yes
so in a sense the headless goes to the
splicing and the list goes it's not
gonna make it it's too weird
it's it has images of headless chickens
and terrible things like that
I mean it is a good thing for a rather
weird operation that you don't expect
people to do very much
um I see what
let's see
okay so let's let's move
you again where we're at we've really
got to make a decision on this this is
terrible it's terrible
okay sublist
I don't agree the sublist sounds like
the list wrapper is still present
afterwards like okay if we have list ABC
I would say that the list a B is a sub
list of the list ABC but there's no
literal list braces around the a and the
B yeah I think you're being I think
you're being somewhat Matthew there I'm
not sure that people would you know what
would you say if you have a list of the
list XY the list a B you would say those
are sub lists of the big lists say
they're elements of the big list you're
being to mathy other people would say
there's some lists in my view case of
sub-expression does it work what's not
gonna work for the list for the list
case no I don't think so I'm trying to
think ahead of the general case what
would be the name it would be good to
have a name that no I agree I agree I
agree although I think we could add
argument I think the other case is a
little bit more obscure than this one
you
you
you
unfortunately elements is just too
generic Cosette is deeply to mathy I
don't even know I don't even know why it
would be quite it's amusing but it's
definitely I'm okay what have we got
let's let's list our nouns okay we have
got you've got sub list
we've got graft which I don't like we've
got some kind of multiple elements which
i think is just too long I mean if we
can it's a wimp out think we we really
should try to do this in one word um
they've got inlay but it
obscure it's too whimsical and lay is
too whimsical patch is too hacky
elements seems to be the most
grammatically correct one word name yeah
but it's really too way too generic
element yeah vanishing list evaporating
evaporating lists - all those kinds of
things I am oh gosh you know must be a
son I'm going to ancient but I'm I'm was
it in oh my gosh I can't remember
whether it was an SMP or early
Mathematica that we had this notion of
evaporating lists that was a disaster
um Alice Lloyd that's an amusing idea
that's an amusing idea too
I uh I mean it's it's - it's a good it's
good it's a good word for something I
like that word we should use that for
something it's just it suggests it's a
yet different data structure which is
some a vanishing list yeah I mean that's
that in the snippet step what we've
already used actually and it means
exactly the right thing and the use that
we've made of it which is a snippet of
text for example um I mean Esther is
going back to a spliced concept what's
that list alit know but list is very
amusing about them but it doesn't really
say what it is
I wish that grafton inlay just had words
that were like them but were a little
less specific little less evocative what
about trying to start from nothing like
nothing list
I think we're getting desperate
very literally would be something like a
list list insertion yeah things like
mini list and so on they're cute but I
just don't think that they're I think
they I don't know what they really
suggest but it isn't quite boy this is
engraft what is it engulfed and then
graphed sounds right but I don't know
what it is never heard of it
I want to come back to the word
insertion again well it's insertion
function insertion function is actually
doing the right thing in object-oriented
programming there's mix-ins yeah it's
just slightly different but I wouldn't
want to use mixin through this though no
Kolk is amusing umm Constitution what
the heck is that can we invent our water
like English what do you guys think of
insertion
now who work list insertion is
list insertion is kind of part way into
spliced but not quite the same I mean
you know X goes to the list insertion
it's a bit technical sounding it's a
pity we couldn't have the word insert
but obviously it spelled the same way as
some yeah insert is already used in
graphics inline I've thought about but I
think it's a little bit too typesetting
insert E is amusing but um inserted
stepping away I was biased
it's just like that's like spliced
spliced is better inserted suggests um
oh great
in lists isn't as an arcade form of
endless twitch doesn't help us really um
most people bear list naked lists I
don't think so we don't want to get
tagged as an on an on g-rated piece of
software for some silly reason
um well spliced lists as dan points out
is that's a noun form of spliced I don't
think it helps us above splice though
but it's kind of now fiying the concept
of spliced Ethan is asking why is
spliced bad splices looking better after
this you know adventure here um but I'm
still not I I don't disagree it it will
be really nice to have something which
is a noun all right let's
graphed again for a second is it to
evocative to crazy what do we say it's a
format that's what I'm sorry it's the
first time I I squared that word that is
a very very bad sign
oops that's not the word I wanted at all
I wanted graft oh dear
he's listing nothing less 10 sting like
that I was just thinking just as he was
starting to say that I was just thinking
about splicing a splicing
doesn't quite help us yeah fragment
we've talked about um come on there's a
way there's something that you do when
if you are inserting something so it
will dissolve in the thing but leaves
its payload so to speak inserted there
what's that feel like when you take a
pill pill what pill is in a pill pill
um but if there's something from around
that um dang this is hard
capsule actually I think that's been
used for some crazy thing in graphics
but um capsule is not doesn't have the
linearity the sense of linearity but
it's not obviously ridiculous
it's a little bit of a heavy thing for
what we're trying to talk about here
retrovirus I don't think we quite a
retrovirus does the right thing as in
[Music]
relation to table
what tablets what tablet as in tablets
like that you would find us in made of
stone and I'm totally confused
I'm looking for synonyms of pill and it
appear second tablet yeah Oh tablet that
kind of time oh my gosh I was completely
confused I was off thinking about stone
tablets I was thinking about tablets as
in a tablet form of medicine
okay let's look back here okay I don't
think listing is gonna make it so let's
let's put them in the UM
I don't know what to name there's some
surrenders activity we probably had
names for this see this is one of these
things where we can't even name that the
we could call the splice tie spars um
just like we have things that we've
named we named with the former names of
manipul a manipulate which will now
never be able to find um
retrovirus really does the right thing
but clearly is absolutely unusable um
what are some terms that
from that that have been used in
genomics I mean I'm not talking you know
like open reading frame or something but
it's not that's not relevant here but
something that is like what a retrovirus
what do people say a retrovirus does it
splices its itself into a
genome probably is what they'd say I
wonder whether there's a different word
for that
okay let's look at the word splice for a
second let's look at it's now informs a
splice sir whoops that's not either
wrote the wrong thing splicer a splicing
allegedly splice can be used as a noun
just as spice yeah a splice yes it can
be used as a noun but unfortunately
we've already used that I mean we it's a
deprecated function long deprecated he
says now he's gonna yeah okay so it's
it's been deprecated for six years
and it was not widely used before that
and it never had a one argument form
you
um
spicy 'm asp lyceum yeah yes I mean I'm
afraid words like infusion just have to
spice
what do we think about that ignoring the
conflict with the long-gone splice from
version 1
which tapa is saying if it's been
dedicated for six years you can use it
again you know in our world of this kind
of language design six years is a blink
of an eye what do people think about
splice a splice
anybody wants
that to me it sounds very similar
displaced well that's fine what's wrong
with that but it's a noun it is the
splice now what we would do with
arguments I'm not sure it is a splice
which will be put into the list
yeah if we can use it as with your
sequence its nouns then this boy we just
spent an hour and a half and we're gonna
have the result that we drop Adi let's
look at these things here okay so let's
look back at these examples I don't know
it's hard to read um okay those people
are saying splice is nice that's a good
that's a good it's a good motto at least
um okay so we insert into ABC the splice
9899
you know what this could work I mean you
know the word association when we very
very very first introduced it we didn't
start you know putting it into an
association is something that we quickly
got used to saying putting it into a
splice is
um
yeah I knew I'd be interested in some
other people from the livestream who've
been commenting on on names I'm I am
basically warming to the word splice
there will be our first example of an
actual serious reuse of a deprecated
name
um I mean it it fell out of use I think
was D documented by version 2 which is
1990 something rather by the time by the
time most many of our users were born
after the thing was deprecated we
probably can get away with considering
it reusable um all right look I think I
think that's where we should um Santa
says splices placed seems the same to
him but I think it is subtly useful um
to to treat it differently um
I don't feel super enthused about splice
but I feel more optimistic about it than
about these other things Jose what do
you think I think I'd like better splice
than spliced and I was now looking
through our code to see if we use splice
still anywhere and I cannot find any way
and the whole code base yes in startup
for sure and then in other places I'm
not looking and I cannot find yeah I
think it's been deeply deprecated for
for like 27 years or something yeah
being able to to say a splice would be
nice like we say a sequence that
certainly would be nice well that's
encouraging I it beeps and says it
couldn't be found
this thing has splicing wolf language
output into external files it better um
I can't believe that tutorial is still
there
well that that should be replaced by
whatever that is should be replaced by
something about templates it doesn't
really matter the thing never had a one
argument form anyway do I need to get
down the physical version one
Mathematica book from my shelf to find
out what the thing it I'm not even going
to tell people what it did just suffice
it to say it did the same it did
something like what's what file template
does now as that documentation just says
there
all right well I'm thinking that we go
with the word splice and still a little
bit unsure but but I think um but I
think we also need to think about how it
works could we use argument splice we
could use that for the up for the other
case an argument splice I mean that that
brings the word splice up to you know
things like Association just a thing
that well we could use the same the same
splice was two arguments in the second
argument we specified their head it
displaces into which my deaths we could
do that you know we could do that let's
give it another day to rattle around
before we start changing code I'm still
not 100% happy
I like Pete's suggestion the splice
would look at the head of the thing you
gave so if you just if H of ABC then
it's placed that's an interesting idea
that's an interesting idea I mean that
that would service a different purpose
independent of of I mean because that
can't that H that would only work if H
is in inert head but there are
definitely cases of that
all right um okay well listen I really
appreciate everybody's input here I hope
we have a good guy I'm still not 100% on
this one but Tim and I I do thank Pete
particularly for raising this and
pointing out that we hadn't really
solved it um and some comments here
about live streams on mail server
functionality that's interesting I I may
be somebody other than me could do that
because I think it's it's interesting to
hear that they're issues of that that
should pass that on um sure ah all right
I thank you all very much um and as I
said to people who are asking about when
was I going to be talking about physics
project
I am hoping within the next few weeks I
will be able to launch that and I will
be doing many live streams I think
initially sort of an intro one and then
I will do a kind of introductory live
stream for physicists one for
mathematicians one for computer
scientists and probably one for
philosophy oriented folk um and they
will have quite high levels of
technicality for those who want it um
all right thank you all very much see
y'all soon